pick right or left these guys are not
related
at all i want guido on the left first i
gotta talk to that guy
how old do you guys think this guy is
i'm 24 in my iroc
and uh you might be 37. you guys 19.
he's obviously a cat's fan so what's
going on boys i got a question from mike
and dr drew
i'm 20 years old and i would rather hook
up with a 45 year old woman with a
motley crew
tattoo on her lower back than a girl my
age
is that normal gang gang buzz buzz mom
issues am i right
well but weird to me is that there's a
lot of that these days
and i don't know if it's a function of
older women or
you know women in their 40s and 60s are
out of the sexual revolution they sort
of
maybe are more sexually kind of out
there because we went through all that
you know what i mean well it seems like
now there's kind of a different movement
where everybody's me too
well yeah though that's a thing dude if
i'm a 20 year old now
okay i look at a 45 year old woman who's
like
yeah i want to [ __ ] i find let's do this
when i'm surrounded by 20 20 year old
girls who everything seems
very rigid and i'm kind of scary i would
be very scared of 20 year olds are
scared
yeah they don't want to do that because
i i i don't want to like they're more
down to
no males the males are scared the males
are i don't want anything wrong i don't
be seen as a rapist i don't
they're very scared they don't know
quite what the parameters are
so even with that fear dr drew is it
able for or are they
able to still but you can't eliminate
your sexual desires is that possible
like i know there's like
maybe this different mind frame like
okay i'm scared i don't know if it's
okay to be sexual that sort of thing
so but are you able to physically and
like whatever it is biologically
decrease the same desire that we felt as
kids
so so in other words you're trying to
take their perspective
like when i was 20 i did not find 45
year olds attractive
but 45 year olds were different when we
were 20. you know what i mean it's a
different population so they look
i think they're more attractive now they
look like well 45 year olds are better
too when you were 20 45 year olds were
dead
i know you know because it was [ __ ]
the cowboy era that's right or they were
smoking for 30 years or whatever sexy
yeah
it's sexy um and so so your question
really is why are they so attracted to
the older
older women and maybe that's porn
there's a lot of sort of wait but also
wait a second
i think you're getting going to more of
a base level theo was onto something
later
like i think that a lot of this is
speculation
i think a lot of young men associate
because of this push of
matriarchal statehood this idea that
everything that is masculinity
is toxic masculinity somehow they get
imposed with this idea that
i'm really horny and i love [ __ ]
therefore i'm doing something wrong yes
and
and of course what really is doing
something wrong is how you act on and
how you behave on it and
being a ledge is is wrong and and and
and forcing yourself on a woman is wrong
but
embracing the fact that you're a horny
young man isn't
and and it's a probably for the 20 year
old brain a really difficult it's a
scary
riddle to un to unfold yeah that's what
i'm saying that's what i'm asking i
think not even to do with the 45 year
olds but say you're
you're 20 years old right now and when i
was 20 you had so much
sexual energy you know and you wanted to
do sex right
but what if but now your brain and the
society is telling you it's wrong
if you pee the wrong way you're a
[ __ ] rapist you know what i'm saying
like anything if you look at your dick
while you pee you're going
to hell some woman's going to kidnap you
in a [ __ ] dodge caravan all this [ __ ]
right everybody's in fear
yeah but does that fear still stop does
it stop
the does it actually curtail the
biological design
i don't think so i don't think so i
think the way you do that is you
scare kids and sometimes that can do
that right but
it does the fear once you've already you
already your biology is already set
it just sort of puts a cap on it and
makes some confusing see that's crazy
because then where does that go
right now it goes bad there's always
there's always a tremendous problem that
comes from the dissonance between what
you're told and what you're feeling
[Music]
is